aside from what's going on in the city
of los angeles much of the world
including right here in vegas is
focusing on the good news of the
vaccines
and brian it's really not that far off
in fact governor sysolak held a press
conference earlier tonight to break down
exactly
how nevadans will go about getting the
vaccine sasha loftus is just outside of
umc tonight after speaking to doctors
about what's ahead
sasha
denise and brian it's the news we've all
been waiting for we finally have an idea
of when our first round of covid
vaccines will come here to nevada now
those first doses that are set to come
in the next few weeks
will go to health care and front line
workers i spoke with a doctor here in
las vegas tonight she said the vaccine
won't just protect her
it will also help put her patients at
ease
we have hope now a vaccine is coming
after months of anticipation a covid 19
vaccine
is coming to nevada i think if i get
vaccinated
or our health care workers get
vaccinated it helps us to create a safer
environment
the first dose which should arrive in
the next few weeks
will go to front line workers like dr
depauli
kashup who's on staff at henderson
hospital i'm
constantly exposed to a lot of people
like a lot of patients and also my
co-workers
who themselves are further exposed to a
lot of
you know sick patients or patients with
kovid she calls it a welcome relief
as our most vulnerable populations are
also first in line for the shot
it should go out to the general public
by this coming spring
it was created quickly but unlv school
of medicine dean dr mark khan
calls it an extremely safe and crucial
tool
these vaccines are safe they're
effective
and they prevent very serious disease
though this is just the first step
experts like kashup agree it's really a
leap
in the right direction we are not the
source of infection for them we are
actually providing them
extra layer of protection so we can all
focus on the fight
to bring back some sense of normalcy
now both the vaccines we'll see here in
nevada and las vegas produced by pfizer
and moderna
each have an efficacy rate of about 95
percent
and they will be administered in two
separate doses spaced either three
or four weeks apart for now reporting
live outside umc
sasha loftis 8 news now